michel polacco spécialistes
aéronautiques et spatiales hauteur de la
conquête spatiale pour les nuls aux
éditions first et michel tommy lee
ancien astronaute et chef du centre
européen des astronautes bonsoir à vous
merci d'être avec nous ce soir sur arte
france
alors c'est vrai aujourd'hui le 60e
anniversaire de l'envoi du premier homme
dans l'espace
on voit que c'est beaucoup de sacrifices
pour toutes ces personnalités salle a
été on imagine pour youri gagarine
également c'est très difficile
finalement de se dire qu'on peut aller
dans l'espace
beaucoup de sacrifices michel polacco
bonsoir un michel de ligny il lui cette
fois il part évidemment puisque lui et
elle est dans l'espace effectivement
c'est une aventure absolument inouïe qui
a commencé peut-être avec les premiers
rêves de l'humanité qui s'est poursuivie
à travers des écrivains des astronomes
et des spécialistes des sciences à
travers les siècles en passant par
cyrano de bergerac jules verne et c est
tout ça à déboucher un jour sur les
fameuses fusées v2 de wernher von braun
qui ont permis la propulsion de
véhicules dans l'espace c'est à dire de
s'affranchir de la pesanteur de la poste
sphère terrestre et à partir de là ça
commence et ce sont les russes qui danse
le premier spoutnik en 1957
les russes qui danse le premier être
vivant leïca la chienne et puis thil ans
plus tard en 1961
donc le premier homme dans l'espace
youri gagarine un mètre cinquante huit
pilotes de chasse 250 heures de vol fils
d'ouvrier choisi un peu pour ça très
courageux et qui pourtant n'aura fait
qu'un seul vol dans son histoire
michel tonini la raison michel polacco
vous vous êtes bien placé justement
pourra et évoquer cette conquête
spatiale j'ai vécu un petit peu sur son
terrain puisque je me suis entraîné à
l'arrivée les voiles pendant quatre ans
et j'ai
plus dans l'immeuble numéro 2 où vivait
sa famille également de même que l'ex il
est alors et les grandes langues spatial
soviétique et russe
pour moi les règles c'est le premier
rang bien sûr mais surtout au delà de ça
c'est un homme récemment courageux
puisque lorsqu'il a décollé il avait
juste un petit siège éjectable sur
lequel est tombé atterrir parce qu'il
pouvait reposer dans le réseau comme moi
j'ai les raids ont visé la cabine il a
déconné c'est notre groupe donc il peut
pas se rassurer par rapport à d'autres
personnes et les véhicules et qui ont
décollé juste avant lui elle avait une
chose qui a explosé au décor et donc
nous sommes vraiment très courageux et
qui était marqué un petit peu le schéma
qui a ouvert le chemin de l'espace pour
toute manière le premier une première
manche assez littéraire 60 ans et est ce
film a été suivi ce qui est important
c'est de savoir que dans ce manga révélé
les faits avant d'être éliminés après
lui il ya eu des vols qui ont été les
plus tôt plus longs jusqu'à fario le
chinois régulièrement des vols de la
mort le record c'est 14 mois pour avoir
pour passer les titres aussi et nous
continuons vers les projets importants
pour avoir des créations autour de la
lune des stations avec d'intéressants
son équilibre des voyages gamard et puis
une coopération qui comme l'établît
monsieur à celle des rallyes devant
cette coopération qui inclut lru serena
cas depuis 20 ans cette station spatiale
de la nasa qui nous font très bien donc
tous carré d'art et d'asservissement
pour quelque chose qui choque l humanité
on va parler bien sûr de cette
coopération
mais michel tonini vous avez vu ce sujet
préparé par vera goffman je le disais
beaucoup de sacrifices est
impressionnant
bon je le confirme en tenue normale on
n'est pas en aussi pour le confinement
lahoud alors c'est pas un compliment est
ce que c'est une mission
le confinement et amour liveris nous on
aime bien à temps dans l'espace
il ya différents trous de mémoire par
rapport à cette jeune dame qui parlait
c'est que là où nous avons les hublots
ont regardé la terre regardez déjà trop
regarder les étoiles
il s'y est rappelé aux entendants qu'on
a des on a des sensations qui sont
vraiment assez haché grégoire des
vêtements des paiements comptants d'un
espace vous dire que sur les 550 elle
qui était de l'espace du début tout ce
que j'ai dans l'espace voulu retourner
dont il ya quand même des élections les
pages et même moi qui donnerait par deux
fois le même si je n'ai pas et même si
je ne retournerai pas probablement d'en
parler que du bien non mais ça vaut le
coup alors michel polacco l'aérospatiale
sinna man a dominé les stratégies
géopolitiques des états et cela c'est un
enjeu vraiment depuis à la guerre froide
telle est la situation aujourd'hui
alors effectivement vous avez raison ça
a dominé les stratégies pourquoi lorsque
les américains ont vu passer spoutnik 1
au dessus de leur tête
en 1957 ça voulait dire que les russes
avec une fusée partant de leur
territoire et est capable d'envoyer un
objet à plus de dix mille kilomètres de
chez eux et s'ils avaient voulu au lieu
d'envoyer une fusée il aurait pu mettre
une bombe
donc ça voulait dire aussi que sur la
fusée soyouz qui a lancé le senior cas
qui s'appelle soyouz aujourd'hui qui a
lancé le premier satellite qui a lancé
ensuite gagarine c'était aussi le
premier missile intercontinental de
l'histoire est donc en parallèle la
conquête spatiale a été à la fois
scientifique et civils et scientifiques
et militaires
et aujourd'hui on est arrivé à un point
c'est fantastique de cette conquête
spatiale a évidemment bouleversé nos
vies nous a apporté beaucoup de confort
beaucoup de capacités d'échangé cetera
mais où aussi cette conquête spatiale a
amené à changer les stratégies on voit
que maintenant
on commence à organiser la fameuse
guerre des étoiles dont parlait le
président reagan en 1983 et dont la
menace a été d'ailleurs complètement
très violente et complètement efficace
pour détruire le système soviétique
d'alors qui était un système extrêmement
brutal parler de guerre des étoiles vous
êtes d'accord
michel tonini vous parliez vous tout à
l'heure de coopération des avancées en
matière de coopération notamment
internationale pour cette fameuse
conquête de l'espace dans notre camp
spatial qu'elles soient remis en
question la question sportive
internationale
il n'y a pas beaucoup l'armement mais je
ferai référence il voit le district de
alishing qui a fait la première
scientifique est clair donc n'est pas
que des années 60 et 1 et puis 65
premières sont claires rappelons que
c'est un voyage s'est terminé par
l'atterrissage loi du pool de l'ex
tenteront cette clause est en péril et
ceux qui attendaient chaleureusement
notre musique à l'époque c'étaient des
loups et donc depuis ce jour nous avons
acquis soleil antilles où ces anti loup
dans le cloud c'est la seule que nous
ayons donc oui c'est pas beaucoup les
rois d'aujourd'hui des cosmonautes ne
font pas beaucoup par moments nous
allons à l'autre des solutions habito
les antilles logiquement tour contre
l'humanité alors justement en matière de
coopération aujourd'hui international
vous vous situez tout à l'heure un
michel tonini les ss laquelle quelle
est-elle bilan faire un michel polacco à
ce niveau je crois que c'est un bilan
assez exhaustif c'est formidable parce
que les russes à partir de la station
saliou de 7 à bord de laquelle avait
volé jean loup chrétien le premier
spationaute européen et français ont
fait beaucoup de progrès mais n'étaient
pas arrivés à un niveau de perfection
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui avec
cette station orbitale internationale à
laquelle participent de très nombreux
pays avec des vaisseaux français et
européens japonais et c'est qu'ils vont
les
alimentez etc mais si vous voulez il a
véritablement fallu une grande
coopération pour arriver à ce niveau
c'est à dire à la capacité d'avoir
autour de la terre depuis plus de 20 ans
un objet qui tournait une habitation qui
tourne et un laboratoire qui tourne et
qui permet de faire énormément de
recherches énormément de découvertes
tout ça de manière tout à fait pacifique
la seule chose qu'on peut regretter
c'est que de leur côté les chinois font
un travail un peu comparable d'un niveau
très inférieur mais quand même un peu
comparable et il est dommage qu'on ait
pas encore réussi à rassembler peut-être
les asiatiques avec les européens et les
américains mais tout ça ça va quand même
globalement dans le bon sens sinon
évidemment ce dont je vous parlais tout
à l'heure c'est à dire le fait qu'on
commence à placer quelques systèmes dans
l'espace ou à proximité de l'espace pour
pouvoir maîtriser les satellites et des
choses comme ça c'est le côté
hélas un peu négatif mais d'un autre
côté les ati de l'espace sont
fantastiques et n'oublions pas que dans
pas longtemps
c'est la lune et dans pas longtemps non
plus ce sont des robots des drones qui
rompt sur mars et qui nous permettront
de mieux connaître encore notre
environnement
tout ça pendant que les sondes voyageurs
partis il y a près de 50 ans continue à
naviguer à l'extrémité du système
solaire vers l'immense vide sidéral et
peut-être un jour les limites de la voie
lactée
tout ça ça nous permet quand même de
rêver même s'il y a des gens qui croient
qu'on ne doit plus rêver de l'aérien
aujourd'hui marteau située 2 mars il y
avait déjà des clichés qui nous sont
parvenues effectivement grâce aux
avancées aujourd'hui la scientifique
pour pouvoir observer ce qui se passe
sur cette planète
michel tonini justement les avancées
scientifiques
ça aussi c'est un grand pas grâce
notamment à la coopération
internationale au sein même de liesse
entre américains entre russes notamment
et français aussi
mais au niveau des sss que tout est
vraiment rozès cap a tout de même des
tensions certaine concurrence qui règne
d'abord un nouveau profil des retours de
nos chronos on a choisi les membres
d'équipage et j'ai choisi j'ai fait la
flexion des six derniers à fond notre op
1 de manière à ce que ces personnages
sont vraiment fermées pour bien réussir
des noms de six mois avec moi quand
j'étais sélectionné l'époque que vous
allez 85 nous servions comme les
affaires des vols courts des boîtes d
une semaine quinze jours trois semaines
maximum
aujourd'hui pas de la sorte est embauché
lycée qui va faire un vol de 6 mois
minimum
donc ça demande des profils qui est
logique différente il faut du travail en
équipe
très gentille et le respect mutuel il
faut des gens qui sont vraiment aligner
qu'ils soient motivés et qu'ils aient
qui est vraiment là l'humilité
nécessaire à ce genre de vol il contera
ses qualités principales des vosges son
roman bien réussi donc c'est ce qu'on a
fait pour cette élection c'est ce que
fait tout ce qu'on fait également des
dégâts et nous aurons côté et en plus de
ces critères nous avons pour la
réflexion nous avons rajouté reçu à
l'entraînement nouveau qu'elle est créé
dans les années 2000 environ pour un
entraîneur n'avait arrêté pour yuma
millions car mon retour améliorer la
ville tellement qu'au mental par les
exercices qui sont autre que celle ci
nateur sur les terrains différents qui
rejoint en montagne dans la région froid
sous terre tu pour un petit peu en
dessous les errements des chronos mais
j'attends mais l'ensemble est cher son
appel une fuite avant décollage tout à
l'heure à michel polacco vous parliez de
la chine justement la chine qui envisage
de procéder au placement en orbite d'un
premier module de sa propre station
spatiale au printemps 2000 21 autres
attend donc de cette année et pékin fait
savoir qu'elle souhaite d'ailleurs que
beaucoup de pays
il envoie des spationautes pour
les expériences scientifiques une
station qui devrait être baptisé
tiangong si je prends danse bien je suis
pas certaine
là c'est une manière de concurrencer les
ss vous pensez c'est ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure les chinois ont
développé un programme de lanceurs très
important ils ont développé un programme
de station orbitale important puisque
cette station orbitale sera la troisième
que les chinois rond mise en orbite et
celle là normalement devrait rester un
certain temps c'est à dire que il
envisage d'y travailler un peu plus
longtemps qu'ils ne l'ont fait
précédemment c'était expérimental et ils
ont envie que je dirais un terme de
reconnaissance des vaisseaux venant
d'europe des états unis voire de russie
viennent s'amarrer mais les chinois de
toute façon je dirais vont leur bon
bonhomme de chemin
parce que en même temps qu'eux ils
développent l'espace circumterrestre
avec cette station orbitale ils sont en
train de travailler énormément sur
l'aîné voyages lointains et les chinois
ont bien l'intention essaye même d'être
les premiers à revenir sur la lune après
les américains merci beaucoup à vous
michel polacco spécialistes
aéronautiques et spatiales hauteur de la
conquête spatiale pour les nuls aux
éditions force
merci à vous michel tonini vous êtes
ancien astronaute chef du centre
européen des astronautes